आज के टाइम में घर चलाना आसान नहीं है। हर
महीने के बिल्स और खर्च बढ़ रहे हैं। ऐसे
में पैसे सेव करना काफी मुश्किल हो जाता
है। लेकिन अगर हम थोड़ी सी प्लानिंग करें
तो घर के खर्च को इजीली कंट्रोल किया जा
सकता है। हेलो फ्रेंड्स, मैं हूं मोनिका
और आज के वीडियो में मैं आप लोगों के साथ
शेयर कर रही हूं 10 सिंपल और इफेक्टिव मनी
सेविंग टिप जो आपके घर के बजट को बैलेंस
करने में आपकी हेल्प करेंगे।
[संगीत]
मनी सेविंग टिप्स का सबसे पहला जो स्टेप
है वो है मंथली बजट बनाना। हर खर्चे को
लिखने की एक हैबिट बनाइए। जैसे ग्रोसरी हो
या फिर स्कूल फीस हो सब कुछ लिखिए। जब हम
लिखते हैं तब हम अपने जो अननेसेसरी खर्च
होते हैं ना उसको फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं।
कुछ लोगों को ना यही नहीं पता होता कि कब
सैलरी आती है और कब सारे पैसे खर्च हो
जाते हैं। उसका मेन रीजन यह है कि आप
मंथली बजट नहीं बनाते। जब आप बजट बनाकर
चलते हैं तो आपको पता होता है कि कितना
पैसा कहां पर खर्च हुआ है।
[संगीत]
दूसरी टिप है अपने छोटे-मोटे खर्चों के
लिए कैश रखना। मिल्क लेना है या फिर आपको
सब्जी लेनी है या फिर आपको फ्रूट्स लेना
है। इन सबके लिए अपने पर्स में कैश रखिए।
आजकल यूपीआई का जमाना है तो हम सब क्या
करते हैं? कि जो भी चीजें हमें खरीदनी
होती है, हम वहां पर यूपीआई ट्रांजैक्शन
कर देते हैं। लेकिन उसकी वजह से क्या होता
है कि हमें हिसाब ही नहीं रहता कि हमने
कौन सी चीज पे कितने पैसे खर्च किए हैं।
लेकिन अगर आप इस तरीके से कैश अमाउंट
रखेंगे तो आपको हिसाब रहेगा कि आपने कौन
सी चीज के लिए कितने अमाउंट खर्च किए हैं
और आप अननेसेसरी खर्चे से भी बच जाएंगे।
नेक्स्ट टिप है अपनी कुकिंग के लिए सही
बर्तनों का चूज करना। कई चीजें ऐसी होती
है जिसे कुक करने में काफी ज्यादा समय
लगता है। जैसे दाल हो गए, चावल हो गए।
इसकी वजह से क्या होता है कि हमारा कितना
सारा गैस है वह वेस्ट हो जाता है। तो इसके
लिए ना आप प्रेशर कुकर का यूज कीजिए।
प्रेशर कुकर का यूज करने से आपका गैस और
टाइम दोनों ही सेव होते हैं। इसके अंदर आप
दो बर्तन रख के एक साथ चावल और दाल दोनों
ही बना सकते हैं।
एक गलती ना हम सब करते हैं कि गैस के ऊपर
बर्तन को रखकर गैस को ऑन कर देते हैं और
उसके बाद जो भी चीजों की हमें जरूरत पड़ती
है वह सब हम ढूंढने लगते हैं। लेकिन ऐसा
बिल्कुल भी नहीं करना चाहिए। इससे हमारा
कितना सारा गैस है वह वेस्ट हो जाता है।
तो आपको क्या करना है कि जो भी चीजों की
आपको जरूरत है कुकिंग करते वक्त वह सारी
चीजें पहले तो आप काउंटर टॉप पर रख लीजिए।
उसके बाद ही आप गैस को ऑन कीजिए।
छोटी-छोटी चीजें हमें पता नहीं चलता लेकिन
कितना सारा हमारा पैसा उसमें खर्च हो जाता
है। इस तरीके से आप जो अपना गैस बिल होता
है उसे भी कंट्रोल कर सकते हैं।
फ्रिज का यूज़ मोस्टली हर घर में होता है।
उसमें कोई चीज रखनी हो या फिर बाहर
निकालनी हो। बार-बार हम फ्रिज को खोलते
हैं और बंद करते हैं। जिसकी वजह से क्या
होता है कि उसका टेंपरेचर डाउन हो जाता है
और फ्रिज अपने आप को ज्यादा कूलिंग मोड पर
ऑन करता है और इलेक्ट्रिसिटी ज्यादा
कंज्यूम करता है। तो आप इलेक्ट्रिसिटी सेव
करने के लिए एक पानी की बोतल ले लीजिए और
उसमें पानी को पूरा फील कर देना है हमको।
और उसके बाद क्या करना है? इसको ना हमें
फ्रीजर के अंदर रख देना है। जब तक कि पूरी
जो बोतल का पानी है वह फ्रीज ना हो जाए।
और फिर क्या करना है कि यह जो फ्रीजर वाली
बोतल है ना उसको हमें रख देना है फ्रिज के
डोर में। इसकी वजह से क्या होगा कि जो
टेंपरेचर होगा फ्रिज का वो एकदम परफेक्ट
रहेगा और बार-बार जो फ्रिज है वह खोल बंद
करने से भी उसका टेंपरेचर डाउन नहीं होगा।
हमारे घर में ऐसे कई रिमोट्स होते हैं
जिनका यूज कम होता है। लेकिन फिर भी हम
उसके अंदर सेल को लगाकर रखते हैं। जिसकी
वजह से क्या होता है कि जो सेल की सेल्फ
लाइफ है वह कम हो जाती है। तो आपको क्या
करना है जो भी रिमोट का यूज़ अगर आप कम कर
रहे हो ना तो उसके जो सेल है उसको उल्टा
लगा देना है। जिसकी वजह से जो सेल है वह
जल्दी खत्म नहीं होंगे और बार-बार आपको नए
सेल लेने का खर्चा नहीं होगा। छोटी-छोटी
चीजों को ध्यान में रखकर हम अपने बजट को
कंट्रोल में कर सकते हैं।
[संगीत]
चार्जिंग करने के लिए हम सब इस तरीके के
केबल का यूज करते हैं। लेकिन चार्जिंग हो
जाने के बाद हम स्विच तो बंद कर देते हैं,
लेकिन प्लग को इसी तरीके से बोर्ड के अंदर
रहने देते हैं। लेकिन आपको पता नहीं होगा
कि स्विच बंद होती है। फिर भी वह
इलेक्ट्रिसिटी कंज्यूम करता है। तो हमेशा
प्लग को ना बाहर निकाल दीजिए।
घर में एसी सबसे ज्यादा इलेक्ट्रिसिटी को
कंज्यूम करता है। तो आप जब भी एसी को ऑन
करते हैं ना तो उसके टेंपरेचर का हमेशा से
ध्यान रखिए। उसका टेंपरेचर बिल्कुल लो मत
रखिए। उसका टेंपरेचर या तो आप 22 पे रख
सकते हैं या फिर 24 पे रख सकते हैं। इस
तरीके से आपकी जो इलेक्ट्रिसिटी है वह सेव
होगी।
नेक्स्ट टिप है मील प्लानिंग। मील
प्लानिंग भी हमारे बजट को कंट्रोल करने
में काफी ज्यादा हेल्पफुल है। अपना वन वीक
का मील प्लान बनाकर रख सकते हैं। अगर आप
मील प्लान करके रखेंगे तो आपको पता होगा
कि इस वीक के लिए आपको कौन सी-कौ सी चीजों
की जरूरत पड़ेगी। मैं इसी तरीके से वन वीक
का मील प्लान बनाकर रखती हूं। आपको लंच
में क्या बनाना है, ब्रेकफास्ट में क्या
बनाना है, डिनर में क्या बनाना है? इसके
लिए आप पहले से ही सारी चीजों को नोट डाउन
कीजिए। फिर उसके हिसाब से भी आप सब्जियों
फ्रूट्स वगैरह ला सकते हैं। इसकी हेल्प से
क्या होगा कि आप अननेसेसरी खर्चे को
कंट्रोल कर सकते हैं। कई बार क्या होता है
कि हम सब्जी लेने जाते हैं तो कई चीजें
ऐसी आ जाती है जो हमारे घर पर कम यूज़
होती है या फिर बिल्कुल भी खाई नहीं जाते।
फिर वह ऐसे ही फ्रिज में पड़ी रहती है।
लेकिन अगर आप मेरी प्लानिंग करके फिर
सब्जियों को लेंगे तो बिल्कुल भी सब्जी का
भी वेस्ट नहीं होगा।
छोटी-छोटी चीजों को ना ध्यान में रख के हम
अपने बजट को भी कंट्रोल कर सकते हैं और
उसमें से पैसे भी बचा सकते हैं। हमको कई
बार ऐसा लगता है कि यह सारी चीजें तो बहुत
छोटी है। इससे क्या ही फर्क पड़ेगा। लेकिन
आप लॉन्ग टर्म में देखेंगे कि आप कितने
सारे पैसे हैं वह सेव कर सकते हैं इसी टिप
की मदद से।
[संगीत]
क्या आप भी अपने घर में मिल प्लानिंग करते
हैं? अगर करते हैं तो मुझे कमेंट करके
जरूर से बताइएगा।
नेक्स्ट टिप है इंपल्स शॉपिंग से बचिए। यह
जो शॉपिंग होती है ना यह हमेशा ही हमारा
बजट बिगाड़ देती है। अगर हम किसी के घर पर
गए हैं वहां पर अगर हमें कोई चीज पसंद आ
गई तो घर पे आते ही हम तुरंत उसे ऑर्डर कर
देते हैं। लेकिन यह हैबिट की वजह से हमारा
जो बजट है वह कंट्रोल में नहीं रहता। तो
आपको क्या करना है कि आपको जो भी चीज
खरीदनी है, आपको कोई चीज पसंद आई है, तो
आप उसे तुरंत ऑर्डर मत कीजिए। आप उसे 24
आवर के लिए थाट में छोड़ दीजिए। 24 आवर के
बाद अगर वह चीज खरीदने का आपका मन है तो
ही आप उसे लीजिए और एक बार जरूर से सोचिए
कि वह चीज आपके घर के लिए इंपॉर्टेंट है
भी या नहीं या फिर ऐसे ही आप उसके पीछे
अपने पैसे को वेस्ट कर रहे हैं। आज के
टाइम में पैसे को सेव करना बहुत ज्यादा
जरूरी हो गया है। अगर आप अपने बजट को
कंट्रोल में नहीं करेंगे तो आप कभी भी
अपने पैसे को सेव नहीं कर पाएंगे। तो इन
छोटी-छोटी चीजों को ना ध्यान में रख के आप
अपने बजट को बैलेंस कर सकते हैं। मुझे
उम्मीद है कि यह सिंपल 10 मनी सेविंग
टिप्स आपके लिए हेल्पफुल रहेंगे। आप
इन्हें अपनी डेली लाइफ में जरूर से ट्राई
करिए और मुझे कमेंट करके बताएं कि आप कौन
सा टिप पहले यूज करने वाले हैं। अगर
वीडियो पसंद आई हो तो लाइक और शेयर जरूर
से करें और चैनल इजी लाइफ वि मोनिका को
सब्सक्राइब करना ना भूलें। मैं आपको मिलती
रहूंगी ऐसे ही यूजफुल वीडियो के साथ। अगर
आपको कोई और टॉपिक पर वीडियो चाहिए तो आप
मुझे कमेंट करके बता सकते हैं। मैं जरूर
से ट्राई करूंगी वीडियो बनाने का।